well a number of years ago I published
this very big book called a new kind of
science so what is this book about well
it's it's really about a new direction a
new kind of science as the book title
says and the the premise of the book is
if we look back at sort of the history
of science about 300 years ago there was
the sort of big idea which was we can
take these things that we see in the
natural world and we can start to
describe them not just in terms of sort
of philosophy and logic but by using
mathematics we have this kind of
language and methodology for thinking
about nature which is mathematics and
mathematical equations and so on and
that's been a very successful idea
that's led to sort of physics a lot of
modern physics and sort of spread out
into a bunch of different areas of the
exact sciences so maybe 25 years ago now
I got very involved more than that 30
years ago now I got very involved in
kind of thinking about is that really
enough is the sort of mathematical
paradigm that we've developed enough to
explain all the things that were
interested in the natural world and what
I realized is that if we're going to be
able to have a theory about what happens
in for example nature there has to
ultimately be some rule by which nature
operates but the issue is does that rule
have to correspond to something like a
mathematical equation something that we
have sort of created in our human
mathematics or is there some more
general sort of source of possible rules
by which nature can operate and what I
realized is that now with our
understanding of computation computer
programs and so on there's actually a
much bigger universe of possible rules
to describe the natural world than just
these mathematical equation kinds of
things and we can think about them in
terms of computer programs we can say
just imagine that nature was described
by rules that correspond to computer
programs what what are the possibilities
for those rules they're normally when we
set up computer programs we build
programs for very particular purposes
you know we've we're constructing a
program to perform a particular task we
write this big complicated program with
thousands maybe millions of lines of
code to perform a particular task but
there's kind of a basic science question
which is
if we just look at the possible programs
that we could construct just imagine
that we start off and we let's say pick
at random a few little instructions to
put into our program what do all these
possible programs what do they do what
does this sort of computational universe
of possible programs look like so I
started exploring this many years ago
and the thing that I discovered was
something that really surprised me a lot
when you look at this sort of
computational universe of possible
programs what you find is that even very
very simple programs sometimes they're
very simple programs do very simple
things but there are very simple
programs that do immensely complicated
kinds of things it's a big surprise from
our usual sort of intuition of
engineering because usually when we
think about making something complicated
and engineering we think we have to go
to a lot of effort to do that we have to
sort of set up complicated rules go to
lots of put in all these different steps
and so on to build our our complicated
thing but what one discovers is in this
computational universe of possible
programs it's really easy to find simple
programs that kind of effortlessly
produce immense complexity in their
behavior so I first noticed my favorite
example of this a thing called the rule
30 cellular automaton in 1984 and this
kind of for me was sort of the a
critical moment in in my development of
my sort of scientific thinking I kind of
view it a little bit like I sort of had
the had the luck of using computers to
do experiments on this computational
universe and sort of being for the first
time able to sort of see what was out
there in this computational universe a
little bit like what you know what
Galileo got to do 400 years ago when he
took a telescope and pointed at the sky
and it was pretty easy to see that there
were mountains on the moon and then you
know moons of Jupiter and things like
that so sort of pointing a computer out
into this computational universe it was
in a sense pretty easy to see that there
were these very simple programs that
these immensely complex things and so I
then sort of got to explore so what does
this mean what what what is this what
happens when you sort of look at this
new paradigm that's created from
realizing that in this computational
universe there's a lot of sort of
richness and complexity kind of readily
at hand and what I discovered is that a
lot of problems that exist in the
Natural Sciences whether it's physics or
biology
other areas things where it looked as if
Nature had some some mysterious secret
about how it produces the kinds of
things we see whether its complexity in
a physical system biological system
whatever a lot of this we can understand
now in terms of this paradigm of looking
at the computational universe and seeing
simple programs do these very complex
things so sort of the first big sort of
result of this new kind of science is to
be able to have a lot broader supply of
potential models for the natural world
and to understand sort of how it can be
that nature produces so much apparent
complexity in in lots of different kinds
of systems so having sort of looked at
this from a science point of view and
there are many directions to that
science you know trying to understand
whether one can use this to find a
fundamental theory of physics trying to
use it to understand sort of things
about the foundations of mathematics
things about biology and the importance
or or lack thereof of Darwinian
evolution and so on in the in the
production of complexity and biology
lots of different applications in the
Natural Sciences but then one could sort
of say well what else can one do given
the sort of paradigm of finding these
simple programs in the computational
universe that do such such sophisticated
things and one of the directions of
applications and technology see in a
sense what is technology technology is
in a sense finding things that exist in
the world and applying them somehow for
human purposes to achieve some human
objective and so we do that with you
know materials that we find in the
natural world whether it's you know
magnets or liquid crystals or whatever
else we find these materials and then we
realize how to apply them to create
things that are useful to us as humans
so what one realizes is that in this
computational universe it's kind of the
same story out in the computational
universe there are all these programs
that effectively perform algorithms that
are rich and complex and then the
question is are they useful for human
purposes so one of the things that's
happened over the last decade or so is
that increasingly we've been able to
make use of these kinds of programs of
just sort of searching the computational
universe for technology finding programs
that achieve particular
so in our Mathematica system an
increasing fraction of the algorithms
that we we introduce are ones that were
not constructed by some sort of human
software engineer going step by step but
instead were found by big searches in
this computational universe